let's start today's lecture with an
unusual story
of a viral disease transmitted from
animals to humans
zoonoses is defined as any disease or
infection
that is naturally transmittable from
animals with a backbone
to humans in 2003
there was a multi-state outbreak of an
unusual
and rare illness known as monkey pox
in six midwestern states with
71 cases reported
monkey pox is a virus related to the
smallpox virus
but normally is only seen in africa
an extensive epidemiological
investigation
eventually revealed that it was brought
to the united states
in a shipment of 800 prairie dogs
from africa during boat shipment
the prairie dogs were contaminated with
the monkey pox virus
by being in contact with giant gambian
rats from ghana
which harbor the virus but who were not
ill
the prairie dogs had asymptomatic viral
infection
but in turn passed the monkey pox virus
on to vulnerable humans
does this sound like a science fiction
movie since the monkey puck's
skin lesions resemble smallpox this
created a
chaotic and scary scenario for the
health departments
importation of exotic animals and wild
animals
harvested for commercial pet trade many
of them illegal
have been associated with a wide array
of outbreaks of infectious diseases in
humans
the cover story of an issue of national
geographic magazine
was entitled wild pets
the debate over owning exotic animals
well no one died from the monkey pox
outbreak
but a ban was put in force immediately
which prohibits the importation
of african rodents
human health around the world today
includes more and more exotic disease
names
like mers and sars as well as
flu viruses with names like bird and
swine flu
diseases are jumping from animals to
humans at a faster pace
than before now
why are new diseases so prevalent and
how are these exotic diseases being
transmitted
to us from animals the phenomenon has
been around for centuries
and over 200 diseases have been
identified
as zoonotic in fact
up to 70 of all infectious diseases
originate from wildlife
in this lecture we're going to discuss
why transmissions of diseases is
occurring more frequently
the methods of transmission the
potential for human harm
and what is being done to prevent and
contain these diseases
now let's return to a more common
zoonotic situation
it's important to know that infectious
diseases
aren't always spread just by exotic
animals
but at times by our pets at home and
other common animals so
first what about companion animals
when we talk about companion animals we
think mostly of dogs and cats
but we should also include other caged
animals in the home
dogs and cats can also become the
vectors of disease
if they have contact with wild animals
potentially
spreading germs to humans for example
one day while playing with our two
samoya dogs in the yard
we notice one had disappeared from sight
we looked anxiously around and within a
few minutes
a dog happily trotted back into the yard
with a very large woodchuck in its mouth
fortunately he obeyed the drop it
command and the woodchuck scurried back
to the woods
leaving both of them unharmed this
happened again
a few days later with our other dog who
proudly carried
over a baby opossum that was infringing
on its territory
which diseases do these two scenarios
have in common
for transmitting illness from wildlife
to humans
well we might be at risk of contracting
the
rabies virus from the woodchuck or the
opossum
or another zoonotic bacterial infection
known as tularemia from handling a wood
chunk
let's take this opportunity to learn
more about rabies
the rabies virus has a bullet shaped
configuration
after a bite or even a scratch by an
infected animal
the virus can enter the body through the
skin
if the wound goes unnoticed which might
occur with scratches
the virus next establishes itself in the
local nerves
where the injury occurred over the
course of the next
weeks or months the virus is able to
travel
insidiously from the skin nerves to
deeper nerves in the body
now immediate disinfection of the wound
and rabies immune globulin injected into
the wound
confers passive immunity and their
crucial measures
for prevention there is also a
six-week rabies vaccination program that
must
follow once
local neurological symptoms develop such
as burning pain at the site
and tingling of the nerves the disease
is almost
uniformly fatal as the virus spreads
deeper into the body to the central
nervous system
fatal inflammation of the brain and
spinal cord develops
there are no reliable treatments
available
but there is one success story
in 2004 a 15 year old girl from
wisconsin was bitten by a bat
at a church service she did not seek
medical treatment
she exhibited abnormal neurological
behavior over the next four weeks
with fluctuating consciousness slurred
speech
and bizarre behavior a diagnosis of
rabies was
established with a tissue biopsy
she was placed in a drug-induced coma
and physicians treated her with a
cocktail of
four antiviral drugs this protocol had
never been tried before
and was basically a hail mary attempt
at saving the girl but
she went on to make a miraculous though
not complete recovery
the time she was the only person known
to have survived rabies
without receiving preventative
vaccinations
the treatment was called the quote
milwaukee protocol
and has been used several other times
since then
sometimes with success but also with
many failures
well now back to my family dogs
an unvaccinated dog or cat bitten by a
woodchuck
or an opossum could contract rabies
and then could bite scratch or even lick
a cut on my arm
making me vulnerable to rabies as well
fortunately our strict adherence to
rabies vaccination
in the united states has made
transmission of rabies
from domestic animals extremely rare
nevertheless today in several third
world countries
that you might visit rabies may be
transmitted from domestic animals
since they are often unvaccinated
in the u.s more than 90 percent of
rabies
comes from wildlife but especially bats
other animals that harbor rabies include
raccoons skunks and foxes
around 40 000 people in the u.s every
year get
rabies shots after exposure to wild
animals
and the estimated cost of receiving
these vaccinations
is more than 300 million dollars so
please try to avoid the temptation to
feed or handle
wild animals but if you are bitten
or scratched by a susceptible animal
wash the wound with soap and water
and get healthcare attention quickly for
post-exposure prevention
try to have the domestic or wild animal
captured by
appropriately trained personnel
then notify the county health department
so the animal can either be sacrificed
and tested for rabies or observed
for rabies symptoms animals that have
rabies
usually exhibit strange bizarre behavior
patterns
especially a fear of water if the animal
is
quarantined for 10 days without symptoms
additional rabies vaccinations
can be avoided rabies is a preventable
disease
with the use of vaccines now
for wild animals one of the means of
vaccination
is by using oral rabies baits
with a marshmallow flavor the wildlife
service program
targets raccoons coyotes and foxes
and is being used throughout the united
states
canada and europe
there are other zoonotic diseases
related to dogs and cats
that are also important in the u.s
there are over 69 million dogs and
74 million cats so it's important to
consider
infectious disease risks let's take a
further look at
two cat transmittable diseases
cat scratch disease is a bacterial
disease
by a germ called bartonella hensela
most people with cat scratch illness had
been bitten or scratched by a cat
they usually developed a mild infection
near the injury site
lymph nodes become swollen and fever and
flu-like symptoms can occur for several
days
surprisingly up to 40 percent of cats
asymptomatically carry this germ
especially kittens
you would expect that once diagnosed
treatment with antibiotics would be
successful
however antibiotics have a limited role
in modifying this illness although
fortunately
the outcomes are rarely serious
toxoplasmosis is another zoonoses
transmitted by cats have you ever seen
little children playing with barn cats
you probably never stop to think about
any associated dangers
cats can become infected after eating
infected tissue of rodents
or less commonly cattle
infectious cyst forms are shed by cats
and the humans become infected through
accidental contact
with feline fecal material
based on blood sample testing only nine
percent of the u.s population has been
exposed to toxoplasmosis
but in other areas of the world the rate
is as high as
50 percent surprisingly
most human infections like cats are
actually
asymptomatic other times
generalized whole body lymph node
enlargement
with flu-like symptoms can occur
in pregnancy if a mother becomes acutely
infected
the parasite can be transmitted across
the mother's placenta
to the fetus newborns can be born
with blindness or mental disability
the main takeaway point from this
scenario
is that pregnant women should not be
scooping litter boxes
should not get a new kitten while
pregnant and should not really be
playing with stray
cats well
what about other small pets did you know
that
reptiles and amphibians like turtles
lizards frogs can carry harmful
salmonella bacteria that can cause
intestinal illness
in 2013 there was an eight
state outbreak of human salmonella
linked to small turtles
as you might expect most victims were
under age
five and owned a benign-looking
little pet turtle the infections can not
only come from
handling turtles but also from the water
or containers where they are living
using gloves for cleaning the
environments of pets is essential
as well as hand washing after handling
them
these pets are probably not appropriate
for children
under five who still put their hands
frequently in them
in their mouths around easter
there are various farms and pet stores
showing off
cute baby chicks alas
i'm here to warn you of yet another
opportunity for your family to become
ill
birds baby chicks and ducks are also the
source of infectious diseases
including salmonella i'd like to tell
you
a true story about my oldest daughter
who was very excited to live
in a funky part of denver on an urban
farm
there were several dogs chickens and
roosters
that ran freely amongst the dense garden
this seemed like a nice
natural enclave however chickens in this
environment
can contract a parasite known as
coccidia coccidia can be spread
through chicken excrement especially
around
feeders this can be transmitted to
humans
and cause diarrhea one of the growing
problems with urban farms
highlighted in a wall street journal
article is that
regular veterinarians are not usually
experienced with chickens
and don't know how to properly diagnose
or treat them
so one of my daughter's chickens became
sick and unresponsive
and that evening she made the mistake of
watching the movie
contagion if you haven't seen the movie
it shows the worldwide spread of
virus-born illness
that was a combination of a pig and bat
virus this resulted in a very late night
phone call from her
she asked about the chance of
contracting a weird bird flu
or other exotic disease from her sick
chicken
which she imagined might have avian flu
or even something worse
the centers for disease control or cdc
has issued an alert that the surge in
small urban farms
is providing the perfect environment for
an
outbreak of salmonella
as people bring chickens into their home
they are letting them walk
on tables and counter tops and
contaminating the home environment
the scenario is not necessarily
mainstream america
but it's increasingly common
in 2012 the cdc monitored eight
outbreaks of salmonella linked to
backyard
poultry flocks the bottom line
is choose your pets wisely
resist the urge at easter time to get a
child
under five a baby chick and make sure
the classroom teacher with the iguana
is also teaching good hand washing
techniques
and consider the age environment and
health
of all the people who might be in
contact with the pets
the best thing that you can do is to
educate yourselves
and children about potential health
hazards of owning pets
and implement strict hand-washing
practices
other diseases may be transmitted from
petting zoos regular zoos or farms
many of us have taken our children or
grandchildren
to places like this long before there
were hand sanitizers
or even hand washing facilities
i remember my kids petting and holding
the barn cats
in a petting farm complete with
unpasteurized apple cider
what was i thinking petting zoo animals
as you now might expect can shed a
variety of germs
without the animals appearing ill
most concerning are young children that
may touch an animal
then put their hands in their mouths or
on food
often pacifiers sippy cups and ice cream
cones
are in the hands or mouths of the
children at the petting zoo
there have been numerous outbreaks of
disease at petting zoos
including bacterial and parasitic germs
that usually cause an intestinal illness
another potential cause of alarm for
acute and furry pets
relates to pet stores and rodents
most of us are not going to be buying
giant gambian rodents
like our opening story but pet rodents
such as hamsters and guinea pigs can
asymptomatically carry a virus called
lymphocytic choriomeningitis virus
this can cause inflammation around the
brain
and spinal cord but fortunately
human infections from pet rodents are
rare
we're already talking about wildlife
animals
in our rabies example but what else
should we keep in mind
when in the great outdoors
hantavirus is a rare but serious disease
that humans can contract through contact
with infected
urine saliva or droppings from rodents
dried urine in dust particles
carries viruses and sweeping the dust
or pitching a tent in the infected area
can cause
an inhalation of the virus this can lead
to a
life-threatening bleeding disorder of
the lungs with
no available treatment since this virus
was first identified
in the u.s in 1993 there have been at
least
60 cases in california residents
in over 600 cases nationally
approximately 12 percent of deer mice
in parts of the southwest are thought to
be asymptomatic carriers
of hantavirus the deer mouse
is the primary reservoir responsible for
most human cases
including those in yosemite national
park
in 2012 there were 10 confirmed cases of
hantavirus
in yosemite and three of them were fatal
as you can imagine it's very difficult
to seal
every crevice in a tent that a mouse can
get through
a portion of the park was temporary
temporarily
closed down of course whenever you enter
a wilderness area
there are always some risks
you can protect yourself however by
being mindful of where you pitch your
tent
not sleeping on the ground keeping food
in containers
being alert for evidence of mice in the
area
next we briefly mention the bacterium
tularemia in my earlier story about dogs
interacting with woodchucks and opossums
but what i didn't tell you is the most
common cause of acquiring tularemia
is from direct contact with the blood or
flesh
of wild rabbits for example
skinning and eating wild rabbit meat
trularemia skin disease in humans is
similar to cat scratch disease but more
severe
another way to contract tularemia is by
inhaling contaminated
aerosolized bacteria generated during
the skinning of animals
since the tularemia bacterium has a high
infectivity potential it can
cause a deadly pneumonia since it can be
spread easily through the air
there is a concern that it could become
an effective
bioterrorism agent
next do you happen to be a venison lover
or a deer hunter another emerging
disease of wildlife
is chronic wasting disease or
cwd cwd
is a contagious animal neurological
disease
affecting deer elk and moose
it is caused by transmission of a prion
associated protein
now these proteins are not even alive
nor do they have
nucleic acid building blocks of dna or
rna
cause a spongy degeneration of the brain
resulting in wasting
abnormal behavior and death in animals
the disease is transmittable among
animals
through saliva and blood and also from
contaminated pastures there is no
treatment but the big question that you
are probably wondering about
is what happens if i eat a piece of
venison
that is infected with cwd
well scientists don't know the answer to
this yet
if you're a hunter you can have your
local wildlife lab
test your deer for cwd
a clinical diagnosis relies on special
testing of the brain
for prion proteins but
another prion associated disease has
caused a degenerative neurological
disorder in humans
bovine spongiform encephalopathy
this illness was first discovered in
england in the mid-1990s
with several dozen citizens dying from
eating contaminated beef
cooking meat does not destroy the prions
nor reduce the risk of disease
acquisition
the risk of transmission of cwd to
humans
is generally thought to be low which is
good news
nevertheless i confessed to not being a
venison eater
well now let's talk about diseases of
farm animals
we consume many farm animal products
like
pasteurized milk and cheese recently
goat cheese which is frequently under
pasteurized
has appeared regularly in gourmet dishes
or on tapas plates
the cdc deems drinking raw milk
as one of the riskiest behaviors for the
acquisition
of foodborne illness this is because of
the range of germs in raw milk
which includes e coli salmonella
shigella campylobacter and listeria to
name a few
these are usually killed by
pasteurization
i must recommend that pregnant women
avoid
raw milk and other raw or
soft cheeses listeria bacteria acquired
during pregnancy can lead to
brain inflammation for the mom and
spontaneous abortions
of the baby another bacterium
brucella most commonly affects cattle
pigs sheep and goats by causing
an unintended late-term animal abortion
sometimes transmitted to humans through
milk and cheese
from an infected animal brucellosis
causes fever and a body-wide illness
that can be life-threatening
the united states has maintained a
federal program for the eradication of
brucella
from domestic livestock for many years
i'm happy to report that the u.s is
very near its goal of being brucellosis
free
since 2001 for the first time
we've reached a point of having no
cattle herds
quarantined however
there have been rare cases detected in
buffalo herds
since then according to the u.s dairy
association
cattle and bison in infected geographic
areas
are recommended for brucella vaccination
the vaccine is a lived weakened
bacterium
note that imported milk and cheeses
have caused cases of brucellosis in the
united states
next let's talk about q
or query fever named for the
original disease with an unknown cause
first discovered in queensland
australia in 1935
it is a worldwide disease caused by an
unusual germ
known as coxiella burnetti
this is neither a virus nor a bacterium
cattle sheep and goats are the primary
reservoirs
organisms are excreted in low numbers
in milk urine and the excrement of
infected animals
but the transmission potential of this
germ
is especially high during animal
birthing
when the germ can be aerosolized and
humans get infected
by inhaling contaminated barnyard dust
very few organisms are required to cause
infection
veterinarians farmers and slaughterhouse
workers
are particularly at risk
in spite of its deadly potential most
human infection is actually asymptomatic
twenty percent of farmers in the united
states show
serological or blood evidence of
exposure to this germ
but don't remember being ill when humans
do become sick
they usually have pneumonia but the germ
has the potential to spread
to all body systems and cause
life-threatening infections
so how are we handling the burden
of human and animal transmission of
infectious diseases
since the 1800s scientists have noted
the
similarity in disease processes among
animals and humans
but human and animal medicine were
practiced separately
until the late 20th century until links
in the epidemiology
and abnormal physiology of diseases were
recognized
to be common
in the present time there is an
important collaborative worldwide effort
by environmental scientists human
physicians
and veterinarians to prevent control
and eradicate infectious diseases and
to improve the health of all species
it's called the one health initiative
we are now able to appreciate the
potential
for repetitive patterns of infections to
occur
among animals their environments and
human animal contacts
this paradigm for global health also
recognizes
that most new human infectious diseases
will emerge from animal reservoirs
deliberate human environmental changes
whether due to
road or dam construction or cutting down
rain forests around the world or human
settlement
has led to increased contact between
people domestic animals and wildlife
this can affect the ecological balance
of the species
in these situations new habitats for
viruses
parasites and their host vectors can
provide opportunities
for exchange and transmission of disease
this has the potential to negatively
impact
the health of each species
we have already witnessed this scenario
with malaria
ebola and hiv
the one health initiative will help
provide essential information
in anticipating and controlling future
infectious disease outbreaks
epidemics and even the next
worldwide pandemic so
for now i hope you've enjoyed learning
about
zoanoses my goal is not to make you
totally paranoid about handling a baby
chick
or scooping a litter box but instead to
make you aware of the many opportunities
to contract infections
and ways to protect yourself my best
parting advice
when having contact with animals is to
improve your diligence of hand washing
by rubbing your hands together with soap
and water for at least 20 seconds
and make sure your children do so as
well
next time we'll move away from animals
as
transmitters of disease to arachnids
in the form of ticks as vectors of
disease
these small ectoparasites have emerged
in force
and have now created a new public health
crisis
stay tuned